via raymonda spécialiste du monde arabe
et musulman bonsoir merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors on
le disait beaucoup de réactions
internationales après cet attentat ce
matin à nice la turquie parle d'un acte
intolérable qu est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire comment est ce qu'il a été
perçu cet attentat à nice dans les pays
arabes aujourd'hui alors dans les pays
arabes je pense si on parle moi
personnellement je peux parler de
l'algérie parce que je suis originaire
d'algérie et tout ça effectivement ça a
été aperçue je pense parce que l'algérie
a vécu quand même dix ans de guerre
civile
malheureusement l'habitude mais moi je
voulais pas je voulais revenir
effectivement en france et dire
effectivement que les musulmans de
france
comment ils ont aperçu encore
malheureusement cet attentat ben ce qui
m'inquiète moi c'est que toujours on
entend les mêmes discours il n'y a pas
de réaction
ce que ça fait des années qu'on entend
le même discours que là on vient
d'entendre le ministre qui dit que la
france ne va pas affaiblir et tout ça
malheureusement la république ça fait
longtemps qu'elle a échoué
ça fait des années qu'on se bat ce
niveau sur les quartiers et je voulais
vous dire notre association que j'écris
en 2016 la brigade des mers qu'on a
alerté en interne on a alerté les
prescrire ces délégués précisé nadia
rennwald la brigade des mers quel est
l'objectif de votre association précisé
l'association la brigade des mers que
j'ai créé fondée en 2014 suite à des
départs des jeunes qui sont parties en
séries alors moi meme je sui travail et
sociales et j'avais alerté en interne
par rapport à des comportements de
jeunes de très très très jeune et
j'avais alerté mais au début il ya
quelques années on me disait non mais le
discours un peu non mais pas de bas pas
de vagues ça ne concerne pas si en
interne c'est culturel
il faut pas c'est de la victimisation et
je pense qu'on a laissé tellement faire
que moi j'avais parlé j'avais dit que la
génération à l'époque en 2016 la
génération de 10 à 12 ans vous allez
voir dans quelques années et
malheureusement j'ai eu raison
malheureusement je dis bien
malheureusement et ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui ce qui se passera encore
domaine ce qui s'est passé avant
malheureusement ça se passera encore
pourquoi je vais vous dire pourquoi
alors expliquez nous effectivement elles
sont quels sont les ressorts finalement
de 2 2 nom quels sont les ressorts
finalement de cet intégrisme comment est
ce que ces jeunes sont touchés comment
ça se passe qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui
manque finalement assez jeune pour pour
ne pas tomber dans dans l'intégrité d'un
simplement mais je vous expliquer alors
il ya eu il ya ma génération à moi qui
ai maghrébine qui est berbère et où la
génération des années des andes année on
va dire de 90 et remonte il ya eu une
génération effectivement et après il ya
eu les aime où il fait heroes lithiques
ont flirté avec les islamistes
par intérêt électoral et ont confiance
aux travailleurs sociaux aux enseignants
on l'a on les a limités dans leurs
sanctions en leur disant surtout faites
attention de ne pas froisser cette
communauté entre guillemets on a ajouté
sur énormément sur la victimisation
moi je pense aujourd'hui janvier j'ai
une colère que je crée depuis des années
à certains politiques certains élus de
la république qui eux mêmes ont
participé entre guillemets avec les mots
à armer ces jeunes qui aujourd'hui on ne
m contre la france aujourd'hui ils ont
ils touchent à toutes nos libertés paco
cathédrale à toutes nos méthodes nos
libertés c'est des gens qui viennent
vous dire écoutez soit vous vivez comme
le vivais à l'époque le prophète soit on
a le devoir et l'obéissance de vous tuer
c'était c'est net c'est clair qu'on ne
peut pas être pire que ça sauf qu'on
essaye toujours de mise et en faisant
l'islam de france en faisant le ccf en
faisant soi disant les le vivre ensemble
mais ces gens là ne veulent pas vivre
avec nous parce que ces gens-là s'est
passé dans les pays comme l'egypte et
l'algérie la tunisie et autres pourtant
ce sont des musulmans comme eux et 1
regard on n'est pas assez musulman et ne
font qu'appliquer ce qui est écrit dans
le coran il applique à la lettre
alors moi je ne comprends pas
aujourd'hui qu'en 2000 appris ce qui
s'est passé avec chardy et le prêtre qui
était déjà décédé à nice on a eu deux
malheureusement encore des attentats je
ne comprends pas qu'on a encore dans la
discussion et dans les dispositifs juste
fait des jeunes qui vont sortir de
prison
qu'est ce que vous attendez aujourd'hui
vous très concrètement nadia rnd a alors
moi déjà junte en un courage politique
quel que soit le parti c'est pas la
faute de macron il faut bien mettre au
courant c'est pas à la faute du
président actuel ça fait des années que
ça dure
macro mais malheureusement macron
récolte se consommer ses aînés pourtant
je suis pas là quand il faut dire de
chaussures macro bien sûr ça c'est pas
macron qui malheureusement a sommé ce
terrorisme je pense il faut redonner à
chacun sa place
il faut redonner confiance aux
éducateurs de terrain pour former des
éducateurs faut former les enseignants
il faut voir qui forme qui il faut aussi
que tout le monde travaille ensemble il
faut arrêter que on est éparpillée et
les associations qui sont dans les
quartiers n'oubliez pas ces associations
sont mandatés par la région sont
mandatés par la préfecture sont mandatés
par l'éducation nationale pour
travailler d'abord sur l'échec scolaire
sur la délinquance
ce même qui encadrent les enfants eux
mêmes sont radicalisées comment on peut
confier des enfants de la république à
des jeunes à des profits soit disant
professionnels je dis bien soi disant
professionnels à des citoyens qui eux
mêmes sont contre la république je pense
qu'il faut inspecter ses associations
comme on inspecte des enseignants comme
on inspecte n'importe quelle fonction
il faut arrêtez arrêtez de faire
semblant de soi disant de s'occuper de
la population parce qu'aujourd'hui on a
des jeunes qui part dans tous les sens
et malheureusement moi je suis très très
très très pessimiste parce que je
connais les quartiers par coeur je
connais le terrorisme et je peux vous
dire que malheureusement j'espère que je
me trompe mais je ne vous dis pas que ce
n'est que le début
parce qu'elle a la jeunesse
d'aujourd'hui en train de se radicaliser
encore plus de plus en plus on a des
jeunes qui sont là et qu'ils ont un
indice
alors vous savez comment c'est que les
jeunes sont radicalisés c'est par
rapport à l'arabe qui parle parce qu on
al arab herbert de nos pays d'origine
mais là il parle arabe coranique et vous
dit comment que ça se fait un enfant qui
n'a jamais été dans un pays musulman
on en rêvait saoudite autre peut avoir
il parlera coranique qui parle mais pas
l'arabe de ses parents et quand il ya
des mots comme ça qu'on connaît et qui
sort que du coran c'est pas un arabe
philosophique littéraire actuelle
littéraire et tout ça et moi je dis et
je vous redis aujourd'hui
si on ne prend pas les chez les enfants
dès la primaire et on ne fait pas le
ménage mais quand je dis le ménage je
parle du grand ménage dans les
associations et on arrête et on arrête
de parler de soi disant j'ai entendu
tout à l'heure c'est pas parce qu'on va
signer laïcité une charte pardon qu'on
va arrêter ils ont rien à [ __ ] de la
charte et voilà signé avec lady mal ils
s'en foutent c'est pas une charte qui va
aller regarder parce que dans leur texte
est sacrée c'est un devoir
c'est vrai qu'on parlait tout à l'heure
avec nos invités de l'éducation et puis
il ya eu ce débat de l'apprentissage de
l'arabe à l'école par exemple il va y
avoir sept minutes de silence lundi
prochain pour pour samuel pâtit la sram
d'habitude est ce qu est ce que vous
nous dites ce soir c'est que ça ne
suffit pas par exemple qu'est ce que
vous pensez vous de cette question de
l'apprentissage de l'arabe à l'école par
exemple
alors moi personnellement moi
personnellement déjà ça existe à rabais
l'école ça existe tous les mercredis ça
existe avec les ambassades maroc algérie
tunisie
l'arabe est l'école déjà existent c'est
par mais c'est pas obligatoire c'est
selon la volonté fait 30 ans que ça
existe avec les consulats ça existe un
rabais l'école déjà existe et si je vous
dis pas qu'il ya énormément d'enfants
qui vont à l'école d'arad et le pire
c'est que c'est les consulats et ils
font le programme de l'éducation
nationale du pays d'origine et ce n'est
même pas contrôlé par l'éducation
nationale
parce que ces consulats qui paye ses
employés mais interviennent dans l'école
de la république alors les cours d'arabe
déjà existent ça sert à rien de faire
semblant
par contre quand on parle de cours
d'arabe alors en fin de compte on répond
toujours où on l'aurait pas alors ils
veulent ça en valeur
mais sa rivale goana l'on va leur donner
des eaux à la nivelle des cours d'arabe
on va leur donner et on se trouve que
l'histoire se répète à chaque fois on a
fait la même chose en algérie et
pourtant ce sont des musulmans et malgré
ça on a eu dix ans de guerre civile
on a eu des intellectuels qui ont été
tués et pourtant ce sont des musulmans
commune on a eu des frères qui ont fait
leur soeur ou leur mère ou et de ce que
pour il n'était pas assez musulman
alors moi je pense la priorité qu'il
faut faire il faut inspecter il faut
arrêter de faire des contrats moi jouer
moi je vous invite à vous les
journalistes d'aller par exemple à
l'aide sociale à l'enfance l'aide
sociale à l'enfance c'est les personnes
qui encadrent nos enfants qui sont
placés il faut voir les éducateurs qui
encadrent ces enfants eux mêmes sont
radicalisées les kwasi ce sont des
produits de la zone alors moi je dis
qu'à un moment donné soit on est dans un
pays démocrates libres et la france a la
une histoire soit on continue à négocier
avec eux en faisant un islam de france
en faisant le à dalle alors donnant des
cours d'arabe en continuant en faisant
avec ed des conventions c'est pas une
charte qui va les arrêter
je pense qu'il faut nommer les choses je
vous l imaginez vous êtes cette
impression religieuse cette pression
religieuse que vous nous décrivez là
c'est un grand nombre de personnes
illizi sont nombreux ces personnes c'est
un mois un petit noyau mais puissant
alors au début on va dire il ya quelques
années c'était vraiment voilà les gens
pratiquer entre l'islam a toujours
existé les musulmans ont toujours existé
en france sauf que ce n'était pas la
même pratique mais depuis quelques
années ça ne fait qu'augmenter pourquoi
parce qu'effectivement les politiques
même les hauts fonctionnaires ont cédé
avec on appelle ça l'exemple
commandement ont fait des concours on
sait que ce n'est pas les cours d'arabe
on sait que ce sont des cours coraniques
on le sait dans dans les associations et
tout ça et la préfecture aussi est au
courant tout le monde sait ce qui se
passe on n'a pas besoin de creuser une
pelle et une pioche et d'ados de
découvrir personne aujourd'hui quel que
soit son statut social sa fonction sa
couleur politique ne peut dire qu'elle
ne sait pas ce qui se passe tout le
monde sait ce qui se passe mais on
laisse
en pensant que les autres vont arrêter
mais à côté eux ils n'arrêteront pas
parce que leur but c'est quoi ces deux
non seulement de faire la terreur et de
commettre des attentats et après on al
islam de france qui s'installe en france
c'est comme si que moi demain je vais
dans un pays musulman et je dis je vais
faire le catéchisme de deux d'algérie ou
untel mais en fin de compte il faut pas
céder
moi je dis faut plus aidé on a trop cédé
on a trop été gentils et c'est une et je
suis berbère d'origine musulmane qui
nous parle je ne m'appelle pas claudine
lemarquand excusez moi et je sais de
quoi je parle je l' ai vécu en algérie
j'ai des amis en egypte et tout le monde
vous alerte
boualem sansal nous a l'air kamel daoud
nous alerte et en algérie ils ont fait
la même chose mais c'est encore pire en
france vous savez pourquoi parce qu on
al jil vous n'avez qu'un mouvement
c'était le front islamique du salut mais
en france on a plusieurs mouvements et
c'est ça qui est plus dangereux et tant
qu'il y aura la complicité de certains
hauts fonctionnaires et de certains
politiques
je pense qu'on n'arrêtera pas
aujourd'hui il faut arrêter de négocier
avec tout ça avec eux il faut élever nos
enfants
nadia renda l'auteur présumé aujourd'hui
alors il y a quelques informations qui
nous sont parvenues alors il serait
finalement un réfugié qui viendrait de
tunisie donc il n'a pas grande
il n'a pas grandi sur le sol français il
arrivé là mal justement alors justement
quel est votre regard sur ce sujet là il
faut pas oublier que quand il ya eu des
choix dans le maghreb le pays où il ya
eu plus de jeunes qui sont partis aux
landaises c'était à la tunisie c'était
il ya énormément de tunisiens qui sont
partis à des eaux des ch
ça c'était y voilà et après il ya eu des
marocains et des algériens et n'oubliez
pas que la tunisie vit une crise
économique
horrible et ces jeunes qui ce jeune qui
est demandé
l'asile politique n'oubliez pas qu
effectivement en france on a cette
politique de demandeurs d'asile l'asile
politique
on donne on donne pas mais le problème
c'est quand on donne aux gens à quitter
le territoire
c'est que les gens ne quitte pas le
territoire et vous avez le droit de
faire une demande
un an après et ces gens là sont aidés
par certaines associations après bien
sûr on n'est pas on est des humanistes
en france mais on ne peut pas donner de
faire de demandeurs de droit d'asile le
droit de ceux ci il faut arrêter avec
tout ça je pense qu'à un moment donné il
faut que les professionnels les
professionnels être un peu moi je cite
c'est quoi être un humaniste mais c'est
d'abord respecter les lois de la
république atmo tout est alors le à
l'instant à l'aller les 27 dirigeants de
l'union européenne qui appelle au
dialogue entre les communautés et et
entre les religions il ya un dialogue
qui existe aujourd'hui entre les
religions notamment sur le trimestre
française que ça fout un problème
justement
oui mais justement un dialogue avec les
religions la france est un pays laïque
de de culture chrétienne les religions
on a dit lassé le président nous a dit
il n'ya pas longtemps les séparatismes
les religieuses surtout les musulmans
c'est à eux de voir comment gérer et
sauver sauver d'abord ces jeunes qui
part dans tous les sens moi je pense
qu'on n'a pas à négocier vu qu'on a la
loi 1905
on négocie pas avec les religions mais
est ce qu'il faudrait bien avec des
travailleurs sociaux
est-ce que selon vous il faut structure
oui un peu à l'image de ces structures
mais une structure un peu à l'image
l'horizon à tous les jours mais pas non
il faudrait les structures je suis tout
à fait moi je suis pour une structure
mais il faudrait pas que ce soit à
l'image de l'église catholique je vais
vous dire pourquoi parce qu'on a fait la
même chose en algérie parce que dans la
religion musulmane n'y a pas de pierre g
tout le monde peut être imam tout le
monde ne peut faire la prière tout le
monde moi je pense qu'il faudrait
effectivement une structure mais une
structure avec des professionnels des
intellectuels mais quand je dit des
médecins qui me tue elle pas forcément
musulman est ce qu'on entend par ekobo
on attend
tous les imams qui défilent et tout ça
ça fait un petit peu voilà mais le
problème qui se passe c'est pourquoi que
ces jeunes aujourd'hui des gens qui
viennent de l'étranger ou qui sont nés
en france aux autres en veulent à notre
démocratie
tout simplement parce que ils suivent à
la lettre ce qui a écrit dans le coran
c'est tout une fois qu'on a compris ça
on a compris dresse c'est pas une nuit
c'est pas parce qu'ils ont mal
interprété non c'est donc ça a déjà
existé les guerres de religion regardez
l'egypte cinq siècles et regardez ce que
mes efforts musulmans fait et nous en
france on accueille deux frères
musulmans comme si c'était des
ingénieurs ou de médecin ou visite des
chercheurs ces saloperies à l'erreur de
la france aussi on ne peut pas négocier
avec nous
on négocie c'est pas possible on doit
protéger avant ma priorité moi en tant
que femme en tant que militante
protéger les jeunes et puis que les
professionnels fassent leur travail on
peut pas quand quelqu'un a un retour
d'asile on doit le conduire directement
à la frontière on ne doit pas lui donner
encore un peu le bras de fraudes non
merci ça comme ça merci beaucoup à nadia
rwanda d'avoir réagi sur notre antenne
jeu